voici peut-être que l'on peut appeler
véritablement la voiture de demain on
sera la voiture de demain je vous invite
à découvrir et peut-être à piloter des
voitures de l'an 2000 la voiture de l'an
2000 un fantasme qui a inspiré bon
nombre d'ingénieurs et de concepteurs
automobiles font partie encore de nos
rêves mais elles existent elles sont
capables de vous parler de vous
comprendre et d'interpréter avec la plus
grande précision de vos pensées d y est
pour beaucoup la voiture du futur et
mais souvent avec robotisation écologie
et surtout originalité premier exemple
en 1951 avec la sabre une voiture déjà
très intelligente
la preuve une seule goutte de pluie sur
le siège est aussitôt elle-même la
capote se ferment quand la nuit bien
voici des femmes a ajouté un sport à
moteur de 300 chevaux une vitesse de
croisière de 200 à l'heure et vous aurez
la sabres la voiture de demain encore
plus autonome et visionnaire voici la
voiture sans chauffeur
une révolution présenté ici en belgique
en 1960 hier l'antenne détecte les
obstacles et les freins font le reste
plus besoin de s'échiner à manoeuvrer la
voiture se sort elle même du
stationnement par translation latéral 18
ans plus tard en 1979 la voiture de l'an
attisées aussi la curiosité de ses
enfants et il avait plein de questions
est ce que plus tard on arrivera à faire
des voitures clientes
est ce que l'ordinateur pourrait
remplacer l'homme au volant
est-ce que les voitures pour marcher à
l'énergie solaire à l'énergie l'énergie
solaire c'est tentant et ce serait bien
agréable effectivement puisque le lait
pas cher et mary soleil alors pour
impressionner et convaincre les
nouvelles générations
les constructeurs mettait le paquet sur
les salons automobiles en 1987 cette
voiture était pleine de promesses une
voiture entièrement informatisé est
équipé de cinq moniteurs vidéo
permettant de visualiser toutes les
données essentielles moteur suspensions
freins etc
ému ni non plus de rétroviseur mais deux
caméras vidéos
treize ans plus tard le monde célébrait
l'an 2000 mais la quête de la voiture de
demain ne s'arrêtait pas là la preuve en
2001 avec cette voiture à fleur de peau
elle remue la queue si son conducteur et
joyeux verse une larme bleus s'il est
malheureux
voici la voiture de demain un prototype
bourré de capteurs électroniques
[Musique]